the first thing I've noticed about this
set is that it's way bigger than our
YouTube videos so what I'm hoping is
that I can go around see the way that
the department's kind of do their thing
on this sort of larger bigger episodic
set and compare that to what we do in
our YouTube videos and see if there's
any cross correlation anything we can
learn and do better here we go ready and
backgrounds there and action when you
have this many people on set you need
one mouthpiece to communicate from the
directors to the rest of the things so
there's an assistant director on every
set like this and usually the assistant
director has two or three other abs
under him and those abs communicate to
all departments and the department to
take that information and they run it
back up the ad chain Sadie
he just talked quietly and everyone has
to listen or they get fired and honestly
I think it's still moment or I'd be it
would be faster if I just shouted to
everybody but you know I'm trying to
make a point of doing this shoot
differently than other shoots I'm trying
to run this one like a real professional
shoot okay if every now and they feel
like picking up the phone and calling me
and being like you know what Jake I need
your help okay I'm glad you're there for
me
no problem dude yeah so it's really nice
you to say that dictates the way to the
production oh yeah just came up now I
went to Disneyland about three weeks ago
and I had my pocket knife with me
someone walked up to me and they were
like excuse me sir what is that in your
pocket and I was like oh it's my pocket
knife you know this regular tool that
most people carry you can't have that
here so he confiscated it and I didn't
want to walk five miles back to the car
where we parked so I'm out a knife now
it turns out that where we're shooting
today happens to be right by really
awesome sod for all things knives
cutlery called Ross color it's been
around I think since the 30s it's type
of place it's gotten grandfathered in
through so many different law changes
you can pretty much get anything
let's go nice Chevy Hey I've literally
never seen Jake that's excited ever he's
stoked
I'm not going to close he likes Matt
what can I say
another thing video village that's where
directors producers and other people
consider and really see what the cameras
are seeing without actually having to
stand behind the camera around these
monitors are makeup artists wardrobe
people along the script supervisor and
make sure that we cover every single
line get all the necessary coverage for
the editors she also records all the
variations and takes variations in lines
as well as what our favorite takes worse
when the editors edit the piece they're
using our favorite tape I also have
these which the direct feed from the
sound system so I can hear where the
actors are saying at anywhere in the
room as if I was standing right beside
me so if you've got a ham and beef in as
you can see down there you've got a cam
which is on a dolly and you got B cam
over there with a telephoto right it's
sort of spying on them as they walk down
the hall you can both of them right here
and with these monitors these small HD
monitors we have hi a simple what color
grades we can see kind of what it looks
like
the final product yesterday oh my gosh
you want better Chloe wave on holiday I
need something a little bigger I lost
mine I took it to Disneyland and I made
the mistake of not leaving it in the car
they wouldn't hold it for me no I either
had to put it in my car or surrender it
and I was miles from my car at that
point give it to my wife because in the
first a go I'd like something else with
a glass breaker on it you got a good
grip though even if the next ones
flipping the first girl I can be a
little more grounded and realistic
because we're not there yet you know got
great I'm going to do a shame to take
words like catching people's I'll I'm
really embarrassed to be in the
situation and like oh that's nice
good great that's solid where do you
want more I just imagine kicking
yourself you're kicking yourself and
about here because like everything's
like locked up it's all your fault
I want to see you like deflecting people
violins and stuff like try not to like
you don't want to be here
yeah yeah same one the thing that I
don't like about these they're really
solid when you clean them but if you use
them they get dirty rings in here get
dirty these are a little too L so I got
it I got another problem with this buck
knife my dad used to carry buck knives I
thought it would be a good idea to get
one they last forever had a little too
few too many one night and I was
convinced that that blade was so hard
that I could throw it into the pavement
and so I tried it and it failed tip from
picture for anything you could take that
I don't think I know now don't like to
get it back you won't recognize it all
right yeah I'll take that would be for
free thank you very much downtime
between shots that's definitely
different from our corridors it's like
for example they're moving onto a new
camera angle now there's at least a ten
minute shift here so you lose you sit
around and welcome to life line see if
we can help you another thing you
probably didn't notice is the amount of
art design that goes into a set like
this whereas most the time I wish you
youtube videos we just use kind of
what's available and we don't actually
do any specific set design other than
like things here and there here they've
added everything including
those deaths computers all the stuff on
the desk
let's take a look pretty cool this is a
straight-up ablet here it's just art
design really yeah
oh my god okay oh dude wait dudes nice
one of the art designers through within
the art design on the screensaver
so they're random code on the screen has
our last names on it was this year this
is actually functional code that's great
yes in grow that into HTML
it'll just like randomly cycle through
you guys name and my class on Fort
Detroit VI yeah there's like all sorts
of little things in them they're just
like tiny little things that you would
never catch all built in Illustrator
After Effects learn illustrator kids
don't learn After Effects everybody
knows After Effects learned illustrator
that's an indispensable skill this is
all built-in vectors and then thrown
adapter effects here on your armor all
right right on your undertake very light
good night Ramona she gonna go like that
beautiful to cover others you take a
yeses here coming up yeah
thank you oh yeah well looks like a new
knife we decided on tonight I have she
got it in the back right now he's
putting it's arrayed away oh look he's
alright
customs to rig up this was a Ruger oh
it's got a Ruger blade Roth cutlery
since 1930 Kitchell blade black and
white photo he's here now what happened
1986 the riots oh wow we were in the
Bradbury Building they looted all with
George Lee Toby get out off the wall out
we have a secondary gate so that kind of
saved our store we were able to get down
here in time to stop him from the mm Wow
me literally had to stop them from
Brianna both windows we have beautiful
display windows they were completely
gone empty cleared of everything or
every single piece we had the bad time
well yeah well if this is the life line
headquarters then the secret to how the
whole thing works
I think it's inside of this box right
here see if I can jump in there see
what's going on please jump off yeah
dude just power no this is a fake thing
well there's power in here now but this
is the set that's just where they keep
on wired in real life
okay yeah I opened it like saying the
secret to life line is inside of utility
time machine is like any fridge if the
fitting if it makes the mini-fridge
that's really got power order and put on
your tinfoil hats definite mini fries
you tell us more in an earlier draft if
you want to define travel you'd have to
put on a a like a time wave form cream
all over your body do you put the cream
all over your body before going in the
fridge because it protects you from all
the time particles
from time burn you don't want to get
time burn time rate is the worst time
lotion the time constant we are we had a
phone's better name
oh it's called quantum cream look back
to the futures like Marty we got to go
back to the past busy hand beer bottle
and like what's this if we I don't have
time to explain just fight all over your
body
extra-strength quantum cream thank you
video is a video title is there's no
time to explain and it stars other guys
just sitting at this and guy was like oh
my god you have to come with me is like
what's wrong in this book there's no
time explain just do this anyway and
he's a Miss games like doing something
is like we don't have time for this just
do it just like more and more
ridiculously good 10 stopping being I
don't know what the ended but like
things like you got like you're having
this claim all over space is like
dragging a mini-fridge like close the
ending is when they stop to explain he's
like no stop
explain to me with Tempest no no be
enemies like look I'm carrying this
stuff I got cream all over our face just
tell me what's going on it's like fine
the moment you take time to explain he
dies and you know 10 minutes and I'm the
guys like you could have explained if
you would just sort of buy her back 20
minutes then that's that time is
editorial yeah that's the one just in
the second extra five minutes they could
tell you but illegally that's really
nice
in the past now but no we are this kind
of project right here is the kind of
project we post some made something cube
something with a really cool in-depth
story this project called the Lifeline
that we're going to be doing it's eight
half-hour episodes and it's going on
YouTube red you can literally tell it
the biggest project we've ever done
because it's this thing we're basically
working every single day on this right
now and cool effects some cool concepts
Syfy's mumbo Jumbo's and gun